14h46 ici à Paris la guerre en Ukraine
avec un sérieux contretemps pour
volodime et ski en pleine offensive
diplomatique à l'ONU l'un de ces gros
soutiens européens le lâchent la Pologne
Varsovie va en effet cesser de lui
livrer des armes à cause du contentieux
céréalier bonjour Magdalena chaud
d'ovnik on vous retrouve en direct sur
France 24 vous êtes en Slovaquie
visiblement le gouvernement polonais a
apporté des précisions ce matin
les relations entre la Pologne et le
crâne sont de plus en plus tendus c'est
vrai que la Pologne et c'est un
de plus de fidèle alliés de l'Ukraine
mais
la Pologne a aussi d'éclairée qui
qu'elle ne fournissait plus d'hermé à
son voisin dans ce cadre de différentes
diplomatiques sur les exportations de
serial mais le Premier ministre mataus
moravitka aussi ajouté que le centre de
je chauffe de
un accord avec des Américains et le
temps
rempli le même rôle qui est alors rempli
qu'il remplira tout au long de l'année
donc le Abder
par lequel en fait l'armée passe va
continuer à marcher quand avant le
premier mois que le Polonais se
concentre plutôt sur la propre défense
avec des herbes plus modernes cela aussi
correspondent également au slogan et
rectoral du parti droit à la justice une
polonais sécurisée et donc ces mots font
donc également partie de la campagne
électorale
mardi aussi la Pologne l'ambassadeur
d'Ukraine à la suite des commentaires
fait par président
qu'il était à l'avant de constater que
certains amis de l'Ukraine en Europe
jouent la solidarité d'un TER politique
en fournissant un thriller avec des
céréales et on rêvant ange verse vie à
dénoncé ses propos comme étant
injustifiés à l'égard de la Pologne qui
a soutenu l'Ukraine depuis des premières
jours de la guerre
depuis le 2 pays ont cherché à calmer le
jeu mais
le conflit continu on va voir comment ça
va dérouler
merci beaucoup pour ces éléments
Magdalena shadownak sur France 24